what's up everyone this is Anthony popli
I know most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain simply
the best podcast in crypto let's kick
this thing off
Anthony scaramouche E who's lovingly
known as the mooch is the founder of
skybridge a global alternative
investment fund and also the founder of
salt conference he previously served as
the White House director of
communications for 11 days under
President Trump in this conversation we
discussed the macro economy the history
of money
the current structural issues in America
what Anthony took away from his time in
the White House and why he thinks
bitcoin could be interesting this is one
of the more entertaining interviews I've
done and it was always great to talk to
another Italian in finance I enjoyed it
and I hope you do as well before we kick
off this podcast first a word from our
sponsor block 5 as many of you know
crypto investors store their digital
assets on exchanges or in cold storage
for long term safekeeping however this
strategy doesn't help them grow their
investment holdings or build overall
wealth with the new block by interest
account users can now securely store
their Bitcoin or Ethernet block buy and
receive 6% annual interest paid monthly
and cryptocurrency 6% is an absurdly
high rate it's the best rate in the
industry I highly suggest you go check
out block by.com slash pop again that's
block five.com
slash pop to sign up and start earning
crypto today skrt skrt everyone to get
into mining and didn't know how don't
worry your boy pops gotcha everybody got
some electricity and Wi-Fi all you got
to do is get a coin mine comm you buy a
coin mine it's like an Xbox or a
PlayStation that helps you turn your
electricity into Bitcoin that's right
you purchase it it shows up at your
doorstep you pull it out of the box you
plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi five
minutes or less you're mining Bitcoin
all you have to do is control it from
the mobile app they provide and then you
receive over-the-air updates that add
new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just
updating your coin mine consumer mining
made easy that's right go to coin mine
comm tell them tom sent you and thank
you later
anthony pomp leon o is a partner at
morgan crete digital all opinions
expressed by pomp or his guests on this
podcast are solely their opinions and do
not reflect the opinions of Morgan Creek
digital or Morgan Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys i'm sitting here with the
anthony scare Moochie in his office in
midtown Manhattan I really appreciate
taking time to do this pop it's great to
be here I got a few questions for you
there that ok you can ask whatever you
will hide so how did you get so hooked
into digital currencies like what was
the Apple the ditch in the side of the
head and said that this is your Eureka
moment for your life yeah there's a
couple of things so I've always looked
at innovative technology and kind of
thought how when you apply to certain
places where's the most disruption or
the most kind of value capture and it's
very obvious to me quickly that the idea
humans are trusting algorithms more than
they are other humans so if you look at
you know Google Maps you trust more than
assets away first street directions or
Spotify for music recommendations rather
than your friend the idea we were going
to stop trusting institutions and human
led organizations but would rather trust
cryptographically secure technology or
algorithms and software seem to to be a
trend that was worth betting on so um
and so the old fogies I mean I'm gonna
fogey a lot of the old fogey so I look
like a 22
oh well that's Botox and hair diver man
I'm gonna teach you how to do that ok ok
you're too young for that [ __ ] right now
but when you get a little older with
dust you up a little bit ok so but the
old folks don't like it right did I
think that they don't understand it
right and so anytime that you have a
technology that you don't understand
there's a little bit of fear there's a
little bit of you know why do we need
something new what we have already works
but as we know you know that's what
we're the opportunity for disruption is
well I mean but the but the government's
hated because the government's like
manipulating the
you know the government's have figured
out that there's a there's been a
100-year scheme or what they do is they
over promise people things like
entitlements and social social welfare
payments and things like that and then
obviously they can't afford the stuff
that they're promising so you're under
taxing over-promising on services and
you're creating these very large
deficits and so what the government's
want to do is they want to continue to
monetize those debts for sure so so why
would a government allow a digital
currency to come into place that is
something they aren't assailable to that
here's the kind of crazy part of this
there's no army behind Bitcoin as a new
clock I'll get to that in a second but
for example when it comes to that the
government's right the u.s. likes the
idea that we can manipulate the US
dollar it's the global reserve currency
etc but there's a lot of countries
around the world that don't like that we
can do that if you look at Russia China
you know other countries they actually
want to get off of the US dollars to
reserve currency and so if you think
about bilateral trade between two
countries that neither have the reserve
currency I have to trust that you're not
manipulating your currency to my harm
you've got to trust that I'm doing that
in game theory why don't we just trust
this thing that we both know can't be
manipulated right so it's kind of opt
out into a non manipulated currency okay
so but but that could cause again in a
modern society I'm going to take you
back to the 1929 1933 crisis I'd
recommend to your listeners that they
read the Lord some finance the title of
the book Lords of Finance by Leah quad
Ahmed and basically what happened is
everyone was stuck on the gold standard
these digital currencies because of
their scarcity have an absolute standard
and so sound money sound money and so
but sometimes sound money in a
deflationary environment or in a tight
environment governments have figured out
that they could use levels of laxity
okay in their currency to create slack
and you know feelings of buoyancy in the
economy and things like that how do you
do that at a digital currency world so I
think that you nailed exactly what the
government's are doing and I think that
there's a large number of people who
believe
you know the Fiat experiment if you will
of having it not be sound money
it has propped up the economy and every
time we get towards these recessive
periods which would be natural market
Corrections we just print more we cut
interest rates right we just continue to
manipulate and I think that a growing
number of people feel like that is one
unsustainable or too you know actually
net negative over a really long period
no it's very net negative for middle
class and lower middle class people
it's very net positive for elites
because when you're devaluing money and
your elites that hold capital inflation
hedged assets you could care less so if
I have a building right here that's
worth a million dollars in 1901 and I
own it and they deflate or I'm sorry the
inflate the money and now it's it's
today and it's worth thirty million
dollars yeah it's still represented a
value to me in terms of that transfer
but a person has wages their wages have
actually declined steadily so
middle-class wages are down about 25
percent as a direct result of this
monetization you that the Fed and people
like that are doing if you go back
there's a white paper that the IMF wrote
about inflation being one of the largest
drivers of wealth inequality and they
basically cite two reasons why that is
one is if you're paid in an hourly wage
that has no inflation adjustment on an
annual basis obviously your purchasing
power is decreasing every year but you
think you're getting paid the same I'm a
lot older than um I don't want to
express cynicism on your podcast but I
want to I want you to express the truth
these politicians suck yeah I mean let
me taste I have an 11-day PhD now in
Washington scumbag eree okay I know what
these people are really like they could
care less about these people they were
sages want to stay ruling they don't
want to serve the people it's about how
do i perpetuate the ruling class that
i'm in and how i hang out with other
clever people and virtue signal to them
and so let's like make sure that my
family is it is okay i could care less
about somebody in the middle of the
country or just some middle class or
lower middle class family that's
struggling me personally i care because
i came from that and so you know one of
the reasons why i wanted to go into the
government
is I thought you know we got to change
these policies and make things better so
so okay so so the Millennials your
millennial you guys are gonna change
everything then right you're gonna bring
in a stable currency and then you guys
are going to accept the roughness that
that stability may present in terms of
the potential recessionary cycles which
are normal for industrial economies
you're get you're ready for that so I
think that we're going to handle what
you said in terms of the politicians
wanting to continue to perpetuate you
basically their benefit and they don't
care about everyone else in a normal
world what they would be able to do is
hey there's a threat right in that
threat is is coming and it's a
technology it's a company it's a person
etc they would regulate it they would
jail them they would do something to
stop that threat right from from
changing that life that they're living
in and kind of the the model that they
have the difference is this is a
decentralized network that cannot be
shut down right and so where it becomes
as you actually get a clash of the
elitism and kind of the current system
is going to clash with and try to put
all of the normal constraints and
regulation and sanctions etc onto
something that can't be regulated away
and you're seeing this in Congress today
where congressmen are coming out saying
listen we can try to go do that it will
not be successful we need to figure out
something else in order to address this
because trying to well the IRS start
with taxing people that are trading in
digital currencies like how are they
gonna do that well well that's actually
what they should do right but you know
I'm on record as saying the first
country to embrace this and say look we
want the entrepreneurs here we want the
innovation here we're actually going to
work with them because it's gonna lead
to tax revenue we're gonna figure out
how to incorporate this into our
financial markets I think they're gonna
have a very very kind of big head start
versus countries that try to go in
outlaws one of my closest friends
Nouriel Roubini calls a chick coin and
they're all [ __ ] coins and all and what
do you say to him so I actually think
that he's doing a lot of entertainment
right but I do believe that he thinks it
doesn't have as much value as everybody
else thinks right so I think he
understands why people are interested in
it etc you have to separate out
blockchain technology Bitcoin and then
all
the other crypto assets raise all the
utility tokens etc 99% of the utility
tokens and what he talked about the [ __ ]
coins they're all worthless right so
he's actually directionally correct on
that when it comes to Bitcoin again we
were talking before we started recording
it's an asymmetric investment right so
it's non correlated to traditional
assets which has some benefits to your
portfolio and then on the upside right
it ten twenty fifty hundred x-type
upside there's just not very many assets
in the world that can do that and so I
tell people don't buy into the
qualitative it's gonna be the next
global reserve currencies that forget
all that if you look at your portfolio
and you put a non correlated asymmetric
asset in it can change the makeup of
your portfolio in a positive way all
right well alright so let me give you my
personal Odyssey because I think it'll
be valuable to you because I'm an
entrepreneur I've started two businesses
sold one business ended up working for
the company that I sold the business to
Neuberger Berman bought my first company
Oskar Capital Management then it got
sold to Lehman I was at Lehman for a few
years and then started skybridge and so
but from my 11 day Odyssey in Washington
I've been at skybridge the last 14 years
I built the company from scratch three
people in a room you're sitting in my
office now there's 80 people here and
just under 10 billion dollars of assets
we've got four offices around the world
I'm an adaptive guy I'm willing to
embrace change you can see a lot of
young people in this room I feel you can
learn yeah the young people make a
mistake because they think that they're
smarter than their parents and their
grandparents and the old people make a
mistake because they think that they're
smarter than the young people but at the
end of the day you can learn from me I
can learn from you were separated by 25
years of life experience but you're
learning things that I've not
experienced yet and so now I've returned
to skybridge I was blown out of my seat
like an Austin Powers villain because I
said Steve Banta was sucking his own
dick I mean big deal the guy probably
couldn't do that because it's probably
the size of an orange tic tac so I mean
it's like there's no way could probably
do that but that's fine
my mistake I own it fireball offense I'm
accountable for move on yep so I'm
badger if we're in Washington look was
that was having final did you see my
press conference
listen yeah as an Italian yo man when I
watched you up there I said that dudes
having the time of his life and then I
read a article where I think the story
is after the press conference you
basically walked in and it was Trump in
somebody else and Trump turned to him
and said you know tell me what you said
because you know mr. scared Bucci that
was one of the best press conferences
I've ever said that was a Naval Reserve
kid yeah get out he was serving the
president's Diet Coke in the study off
the Oval I love your I just had I just
had dinner with Don jr. last night I
love the president I think he's an
awesome guy I think he's flawed we're
all flawed you got to watch it with the
he's not a racist but you can't say
racist [ __ ] okay because what ends up
happening is you're the leader of the
free world the mantle of leadership
requires you to just get as far away
from that stuff as possible if we're
having a debate over whether or not the
president is racist he's not racist and
I'll defend him till the cows come home
on that but he can't be saying racist
oriented she Ettore just stupid but
let's move on from that and the stuff
he's saying about digital currency right
now is to me is a I'm a contrarian so
the fact that he's railing on it and
Steve Newton is railing on it means okay
it has arrived but I won't explain this
Odyssey to you because I think it's
important so I come back to my firm the
firm has been wounded by our merger
potentiality with the Chinese the HTA
guys were great guys by the way Sofia
says that we can't sell for them we're a
national security threat ha ha no
problem the deal fades I'm back at
skybridge working again no whining no
complaining life is what it is but now I
got a look at the world and where the
world is right now Jamie Dimon says that
he hates digital currencies and he hates
Bitcoin and all this stuff okay and then
launch and then he's gotta walk it back
because he's got five 600 people working
for him and so Jamie and I have all the
respect in the world of Jamie he's
probably seven or eight years older than
me he's one of the smartest people I
know in financial services and then BOOM
he's caught in a generational blind spot
okay and by the way same generational
blind spot that I would be caught in
same generational blind spot that you
go your partner would be caught in so
now Jamie's gotta walk it back and so I
turn to my staff here my young staff I
said okay there's something here I don't
know enough about it we have our soft
conference we're gonna bring a group of
people from the crypto space and we try
to get you guys there unfortunately you
couldn't connect to learn more about it
and and trust me I'm 55 there's a lot of
55 year olds and financial services that
know nothing about your space so I'm
gonna tell you where I am personally now
after evaluating it for a year I'm still
skeptical I'm not gonna say that I'm not
yeah but I do think it will exist I
think there are there's value to the
notion that I can exchange value with
you confidentially and I can exchange it
through a mechanism that looks very
secure know that those mechanisms will
get even more secure in the future than
they are today my issue is a political
issue because I understand how
governments work and I'm gonna take your
listeners through a quick history lesson
on our money in 1929 1933 we tightened
at a time when we needed to loosen it
wasn't until Franklin Roosevelt got the
reins in 1933 that he took us off the
gold standard and created some slack
which created some relief for everybody
now that's always temporary relief you
know when they're devaluing it's always
temporary relief but relief was needed
from political purposes and so we have
to be very very careful with dogmatism
and absolutism because what happens is
it's like Mike Tyson said everybody's
got a plan until the punch in the face
you're the leader of the United States
during a recession and you need to offer
relief immediately so you don't have a
revolution you're gonna take the
country's currency off the gold standard
so that makes me worry about Bitcoin
because bitcoin is a fixed standard it's
a fixed supply and it will trade
relative to what's going on in the world
irrespective of the world and we're
respectable governmental manipulation
can be both stipulate that yes that
makes me wary as a practical person
because I know what governments will do
in times of expediency george w bush
said I'm a conservative I believe in
free market principles the world was
coming to an end
he he veered to the left very hard and
he sent the trillion dollars to the
banking system through tarp to save tarp
what do you think about tarp
well I think it worked and I liked tarp
but it was if you know if they allowed
free-market principles they had allowed
Bitcoin ashore digital currency like
absolutist every bank in the country
would have failed you would have gone to
25-30 percent unemployment
we're not smarter than our grandparents
35 percent unemployment you're gonna
have a revolution here just the way it
works so so yeah you had to send the
money to tarp it got paid back and they
got paid back with a profit a lot of
people you know don't understand that
that was valuable to the US government
but the truth of the matter is that's
what governments do in times of crisis
they veer very very hard to the left
yeah not saying it's right but I'm
saying that's what this would have duked
okay so now the second problem that I
have and it's just quick history on our
money so the money is now devalued we go
to war we have Bretton Woods we just
separate celebrated 75th anniversary of
Bretton Woods they fix the Exchange Rate
Mechanism among the Western capitalist
powers we have a Marshall Plan we put a
trade system together that's unfair to
the United States to help the rest of
the world grow we have deficits we want
to fight communism everywhere we run up
a big deficit in the 60s to fight a
proxy war against communism in Vietnam
we kill 60,000 Americans roughly we're
running very large deficits and so now
the price of our currency which was
fixed at Bretton Woods to be $35 an
ounce of gold is released in August of
1971 Richard Nixon says [ __ ] we got to
monetize our debt in order to pay back
and so therefore were unclipping our
dollar from gold the dollar is gone from
$35 an ounce 1971 2019 it's roughly 1350
an ounce we crushed our currency the
currency is down ninety seven and a half
percent okay who did that the Chinese
then said okay great we're gonna reform
our economy they linked their currency
to our currency okay we allowed that to
happen because we were fighting the
Russian
Nixon opened us to China and then he
said okay great you can link your
currency to our currency even though
you're creating industrial factories and
a mercantilist economy which should
drive your currency upward we're gonna
allow you to link your currency to our
currency which will increase your
ability to grow because you're gonna be
operating in the world stage with a
devalued currency you're just the United
States currency so this works for China
they're clipping off ten twelve fifteen
percent growth they created an economic
miracle they go from an impoverished
agrarian society 40 short years later to
the second largest economy in the world
they got problems China I'm not saying
they don't but they've done that and
part of that was being able to hit him
kick you know pitch themselves to our
currency like a rocket ship for them go
to the other side of the world okay what
do you think that what do you think the
Germans did Germans same thing say hey
man this is great let's link up with all
these southern European countries
they've got a devalue every five years
they're swimming naked in the
Mediterranean drinking guzo retiring at
age 55 let's link up with them and if
you price the deutsche mark today versus
where the euro is trading it's at about
a 20 to 23 percent premium and lo and
behold the Germans they reform their
labor market and they create this
industrial mercantilist exporting
powerhouse right they have a very large
economy they have a budget surplus and
they're at full employment all done
through currency manipulation all done
through rigging the system to benefit
Germany see the Trump understands that
that's why he's mad at them so now here
we are the United States is sitting on
22 trillion dollars of debt we have the
largest military we just left the
largest economy and we're direct
beneficiary of great resources here and
protected by two oceans but political
leaders are going to want to annihilate
digital currencies because they will put
to risk the manipulation that political
leaders have been able to do over the
last 100 150 years of our manufacturing
society so so again I'm not saying that
gonna work of course but I'm just
telling you the problem that you're
gonna
half of getting Bitcoin to be a major so
let me they're not Bitcoin digital
currency in general maybe it's a theorem
the ones that you like I don't yeah so
lemme everything you just said
completely agree with right from up from
a history lesson standpoint one thing I
think a lot about is if you zoom even
farther out right the fall of every
great Empire has been the debasement up
their currency right to go back to
ancient Athens Romans etc when the
currency starts to be devalued away
right eventually the car C goes in the
hips worthless it does not happen
overnight it takes decades if not
hundreds of years right what worries me
is you think America is gonna cheat that
system pump cheap that system in what
sense oh you haven't you have the rise
of the American Empire starts in 1776 is
two hundred and forty-three years old
it's the longest standing Republic I
mean the Roman Republic probably ended
after 225 years hmm so you think we
build cheat history but my thing is
every great Empire Falls I don't think
that anything horrific is gonna happen
in my lifetime I hope it doesn't happen
right I actually you know look I was in
the Army right and tend to be very
American minded but at the same time I
think that there's very real risks with
that the structural issues that we're
facing and the part to me that well a
political leadership sucks okay they'll
blow an unbelievable thing I mean they
got handed a unbelievable country some
of it was locked so I'm who was our
geography and natural resources and
after the end the Second World War they
got handed this unbelievable country
when the baby boomers which I am one off
okay so I feel grounded in being able to
criticize baby boomers when they got
handed the baton from the greatest
generation the world war two generation
we blew it mm-hmm we [ __ ] sucked
because we killed a million people in
the Middle East as you know because you
were in the army
seventy thousand American servicemen and
women killed you got set
and I'm sorry wounded 7,000 dead you
know 20 to die for PTSD every day we
blew out a twenty two trillion dollar
debt we blew up our infrastructure our
bridges roads tunnels airports are
crumbling look like third world
countries educational system sucks the K
through 12 educational system totally
uneven totally unfair Common Core is a
disaster I don't know anybody that even
likes it or thinks it makes any sense
you got to put your kids in private
school if you're smart now to get them
avoid common core and then you got an
industrial policy that it's an absolute
mess because there's no policy so the
political leadership in the country
which controls 25 or if you take state
and local governments 50% of the
country's GDP they suck I mean they
absolutely unmitigated ly suck they
perpetuate these false arguments and
they gerrymander themselves into
permanency in their districts while your
country my country the one that we love
is actually crumbling so I don't think
we can cheat history unless we have a
huge wake-up call okay somebody like you
as an example it's got to be your
generation that does it because my
generation sucks and we won't be able to
won't be able to do we don't have any
political leaders in my generation that
can do it but it has to be somebody from
your generation that says okay this
completely sucks
you guys blew it but we're gonna take it
over and we're gonna not focus on left
and right but we're gonna focus on right
or wrong and we're gonna pick policies
that are gonna work I'm gonna tell the
American people the truth it's gonna
take 25 to 30 years to fix these
problems it's not gonna happen overnight
there's no quick fix no quick solution
what would you do to fix them what do
you think the solutions are well I mean
there's a hundreds of them but I mean
you know and and here's the thing okay
Bitcoin okay could have a role okay it
could be another currency another
commodity it could be like gold is or
platinum or palladium it could store
value it could be yes I might I'm not
disputing it I'm not Nouriel Roubini
where I think it's [ __ ] coins I actually
think your generation is embracing it
and what your
saying about algorithms and artificial
intelligence and the future of what's
gonna be trusted and what isn't I
believe in all that stuff but if we can
get your generation focused on this and
put leadership together it says ok here
is the strategic plan for America we
want to cheat history we want to return
we want to turn a republic that
typically lasts two to 250 years into a
500 year Republic here's what we need to
do we have to invest in our
infrastructure and we have to invest in
our educational system and we have the
right size our deficit now the good news
is we can right size our deficit bad
news is is that it's it's got to be
energy related because you know we can
take the energy out of the ground we
just have to figure out a way to burn it
cleanly you know these climate Accords
and all this nonsense not gonna help we
have to figure out it's a carbon-based
world at least for another 50 to 100
years we don't want to coke up the
environment having like a frat party
with the environment right now and then
we want our kids to live in the frat
house on Sunday morning with the beer
and the bongs everywhere the bong water
spilled on the rug now we got to figure
fix the environment right so you're not
gonna fix it by signing climate Accords
because no one's adhering to them but
you have to figure out if there's a way
the same way we desalinate water is
there a way that we can burn this energy
more cleanly or is a way we can filter
the energy or is there a way to create
photosynthesis through technology where
you're literally taking the carbon in
and doing exactly what a plant or a tree
would do and convert it back into oxygen
and again I don't know the answer to
that because I'm not a scientist but to
me your generations got to figure that
out we have to figure out a way yes
clean energy wind and and things like
solar and stuff like that but at the end
of the day you're gonna have to figure
out a way to burn carbon more cleanly if
you can do that you can solve the
deficit crisis because through fracking
you know the United States owns I don't
know 30 percent of the land you can
google it it's by 28 or 30 percent
underneath that land is an unbelievable
amount
of energy trillions of dollars of energy
that's owned by the United States
effectively so if you look at the u.s.
balance sheet it's probably got sixty
trillion dollars on its balance sheet
and 22 trillion dollars of debt look at
it from that perspective and so then you
need to plan 25-year plan of how you're
going to defeat that deficit strengthen
your dollar by doing that and strengthen
your economies secondary plan you need
an educational plan K through 12 the
technical jobs training plan so people
don't necessarily have to go to college
but they can make high income in a
passion that they have that they can
learn more about it get technically
trained for I mean the infrastructures
disasters you got water pipes in the
city it's crazy there 95 years old what
are these people doing okay I mean what
are you doing what are you doing with
the money okay how about the 92 billion
dollar yeah you got a 92 billion 92
billion dollar budget for New York City
two hundred billion dollar budget for
the state that's three hundred billion
dollars what are you guys doing that's
an 8 that's 8 percent seven point seven
five percent of the federal government's
budget to be spent in the city of New
York in the state of New York what what
are you guys doing where is the money
where's the audit on the money okay so
you need an anti-corruption plan you
need an infrastructure plan you needed
industrial policy plan there's no living
politician that wants any of that to
happen because they are feathering their
beds short-term okay to benefit
themselves short-term and their families
and they could care less about the rest
of the United States so until you can
break that fever and get people in the
game that are committed the public
service is not going to happen but but
you know your your podcast is about
digital currency and so my conclusion
after looking this thing for your plus
is that I think I think it's sustainable
I think it's going to be here I think
it's going to be to be a
I think is gonna be a future where you
know better than me I don't know which
currencies gonna be there and put the
bot the blockchain is gonna get tighter
and more reformed and and more secure
people gonna have more confidence in it
and I don't think it can be stopped
actually I don't I don't see even though
it's going to upset governments and it's
got that whole process that I just
explained to you of devaluation and you
know keeping people short-term happy
it's gonna be present I just don't know
I don't know I don't know how big of an
impact it's gonna have because the
players like the government again the US
government for trillion-dollar to have
budget they're controlling 22 percent of
the u.s. GDP they don't want it they
don't like it and they're gonna do
everything they can to disrupt and break
it the last thing I'll say is you said
something earlier that I think is the
absolute key which is you I others
probably even listen to this podcast to
understand how the games played and so
we take wealth and we get it out of the
currency into real assets and that
actually benefit from the inflation
right what excites me I think about
Bitcoin specifically is as a store a
value I think there's a lot of people
who they're not investors they don't
understand asset management or portfolio
construction or real assets versus
currencies etc but if there is a store
of value currency that they are able to
simply park their wealth in and over
time rather than being devalued away
because it is that deflationary model
they actually can preserve their wealth
or even increase their wealth I think
that's a really powerful change totally
but but to your point I think that
there's a very very bumpy road from here
to that being the kind of you know
default state and that's kind of what
makes it you know one exciting but also
to the unknown yeah well I mean what you
just said is is is more I think the
future is and and so look I mean the
Bible says the poor were always being
among us pom okay but the rich will
always be among us too what has made the
United States so successful is that very
thoughtful policy leaders even if they
had racism in the country and even if
there were bad things
the country and your Italian
grandparents my Italian grandparents
were discriminated against they created
a free-market meritocratic based system
where families could come here from
wherever they were coming from and do
really really well we have to figure out
a way to maintain that system mmm
and if we can do that the future is very
very bright now the great news about us
is that human you know human beings is
that we were constantly innovating
digital currency is a representation of
that and so if you just stay out of wars
you know 10 15 20 years from now they'll
be vertical farming they'll be
artificial intelligence they'll be
increased automation and manufacturing
that will probably reduce prices further
there's a lot of great things happening
and so I do think digital currencies
would be a big part of that future for
sure the question everyone wants to know
is do any Bitcoin I don't own any
Bitcoin right now no but that's not to
say that I won't and it's not to say
that I'm not open to potentially
creating you know we're a fun to fund so
if you said to me could I have a fund of
digital currencies a fund of funds of
different funds that trade in currencies
yes I don't know any Bitcoin right now
but if you come and see me if you invite
me back on your podcast at a year I bet
I'll have a different answer all right
awesome one that you sort you're taking
the time to do this I know your palm is
easy good luck
keep up the good work okay make sure you
keep your name out there okay right now
I don't think you're that well-known mom
okay get your name out there a little be
more aggressive with that okay Anthony
is gonna give me all the the secrets to
the only thing is I don't think I could
have don't go into the government
they've been on a national stage
although although if you end up in the
government man I gotta tell you you know
if try to maximize if you could only
spend one mooch which is 11 days try to
maximize it like I did you're a legend
for hitting the national press with the
finger guns
all right thanks all right guys thanks
so much for listen to that podcast
before I let you go one more word from
our sponsor blocked by their new
interest account allows you to securely
deposit your Bitcoin or Ethernet block
by and receive 6% annual interest paid
monthly and cryptocurrency this rate
actually compound so you receive a 6.2
per
EP y which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block Phi and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block 5
comm / pump again block 5 comm / pop to
sign up and start earning interest on
your crypto today everyone to get into
mining and didn't know how don't worry
your boy pops gotcha
everybody got some electricity in Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mine it's like an
Xbox or a Playstation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box
you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine com
tell them pump Sencha and thank me later
hey everyone
pop here if you like this episode of off
the chain and want to help us to take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
home page just scroll down until you see
the five blank stars take you 15 seconds
to fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain